[Music]
in good-girl news no such name yeah
submitted by Yasmin yes yes mean a
Colombian drug dog has been moved to a
new location to ensure her safety from
local gangs
oh man
so that drug dogs been catching all the
bad guys so they're like [ __ ] that dog
want to kill them
or tell her he has found almost 10 tons
at one time I mean what did they do they
took the dogs they put it to another
state and they painted the coat white on
the [ __ ] machine is protection miss
protection for dogs it's adopted by
another family it's like that's not the
same dog by the way that dog is a coke
ad that's how know it's like jonesing
for coke that's how it's gonna say is
that how they trying to talk over there
dude let's get some coke that's why they
like what they do with the dogs is they
get them addicted to it so they sniff it
so when they find it they give them a
rag that has like whatever it they're
jonesing for and they get the sniffing
that's [ __ ] dog addicted the same way
humans do yeah they get him hooked on
that smack I thought they just put like
snacks and things next to coke and they
just remember if they find a coke they
get a treat yeah I'm not sure how they
do for drugs but when I was truffle
hunting with these little dogs they
actually treat them to talk truffles in
there it's very like actual with
truffles yeah let me find the trouble
they don't give them a truffle and the
treat so they know also still the treat
though the treat is the positive
reinforcement yeah but they also get fed
the truffles and felton that's [ __ ]
wild they just got fed [ __ ] $4,000 so
four grand dog like god damn when you
went truffle honey the dog doesn't just
end up eating all the [ __ ] truffles
does so she has to stop them before they
destroy the truffle is it really truffle
hunting if it can't run or is it just a
truffle finding find locating truffle
locating truffle scavenging you find
truffle just [ __ ] blast it
they'll be fighting inside the soil so
you have to wait for it yeah but it's
not running from you like I see it going
it's not like a fox so some of the
troubles that we eat has dog [ __ ]
mouth and slobber in it no I mean they
clean up but it was in that mouth that
they had a [ __ ] wedge out don't you
see a bid for it and then they pulled
the dog away and then they dig it
themselves there's a fish in Japan that
these fishermen they they train these
birds and then they [ __ ] have a
little rope around their neck so they
don't swallow the fish and then they go
dive and they get all the fish and then
they make them barf it out and then
people eat that fish that's so much work
[ __ ] that that's their fishing pole
though do they train the birds to just
go and grab all the fishes up and then
they come over and they [ __ ] breathe
they throw them out again and then
finally they undo the rope and they let
them actually catch a fish there's weird
[ __ ] like that nature like there's this
like bacteria that like climbs into gets
into like a bug right and then it takes
it over the bug the bug climbs up all
the way to the top of the thing and then
just it explodes and that's how it
spreads and seed all over the place like
how crazy is that there's like a
symbiotic like virus that doesn't the
slugs or snails - and there's also like
mice does they will take over the
mouse's head and make the mouse or that
controls it from the brain yeah and run
into cats and the cats eat it and it's
like how it spreads its whole thing like
pickle Rick man that's the dark arts
right every time I see a coke boss like
oh man the price of coke just went up
not they do cocaine my but you know it's
just now it's gonna be more expensive
and you know the cops are just taking
the coke doing some and selling it to
their friends really cops get the best
coke man they get the best coke I bet
yeah moving right along this is summer
I was cute I don't even see where her
face is in this thank you oh there it is
that looks like a month she's a German
Shepherd that looks like a weird German
she has a $70,000 bounty on her oh now
we just spread that we're gonna spread
the protection of her okay
don't with just get a dead German
Shepherd from a shelter oh yeah that
they euthanized yes oh yeah until you
see the dog and then they're like oh
[ __ ] that you just jacked us for 70 K
and now there's an eighty plastic
surgery yeah so she's six years old
she has sniffed out tons and tons of
cocaine you know what sad is some of
these countries they don't have anything
but that has their major export and so
many people rely on it that there's just
this huge dependency and it's like how
do they leave that drug trade the drug
war is just simply a war on poor people
yeah like the CIA smuggles all the drugs
in I mean Pablo Escobar was son was like
my dad worked with the CIA they smuggle
it all in they're smuggling heroin right
now they smuggled into cocaine they
always do that and then they're the ones
who outlaw it so they could fill your
the privatized prisons up and no one
gets too much power because once they do
they just replace they whack em out and
they get a new guy off they create the
monster so he can fight them on so
conspiracies out there was the war on
Afghanistan was because during the
Taliban 's rule they've really decreased
a number of opium production and then we
went back in there for terrorism but
we're in the opium trade yeah and so
there's a lot of stories of soldiers
coming back and saying you know what we
did is we were just protecting opium
fields or something for some reason we
were just you know patrolling around
there well pharmaceuticals use it for
oxy cotton and stuff like that but then
they flood the market to get everybody
hooked and depress and all that it's
like dark art [ __ ] that's some dark arts
man that's true cuz I'm like we where do
the opioids come from and where are as
so is it Afghanistan you have produce it
there okay cuz I thought it was a heroin
problem but damn I know it is it is a
heroin problem because what happens is
they can't afford prescription
medication anymore and actually a giant
pharmaceutical CEO just got arrested for
basically bribing doctors to prescribe
over prescribed medication so the game
is get them hooked on opioids and then
cut them off and then they go to the
streets to try and get some hair on when
a woman I'm with the 80s crack epidemic
which was systematic which was like
flood the ghettos would crack pull off
the jobs then you throw all the males in
jail and it just disintegrates every
that was the Noriega scandal right yeah
the iran-contra affair that contra yeah
yeah so that's what's being done right
now a heroin so this is a conspiracy
that actually became true and there's
files on it and it's called the
iran-contra scandal for those of you
guys who don't know what ended up
happening was the US government allowed
the drug crack epidemic to happen in the
ghettos because they said well you know
they're like poor and whatever they can
die off it doesn't matter they were
using that money through the drug trade
to fund these guerrillas in was a Panama
or rebels rebels to fund their war so we
wanted contraire America American
dictator so we could control them I
don't know if it was for the banana
trade or something there was something
going on where we wanted our dictator to
be in power so we keep control of that
and what was it with the Iran thing
there was something there was a reason
why Iran was also involved it might be
oil or something like that but there was
all this [ __ ] going on with the CIA and
that's when freeway Rick Ross was really
big and he had free rein to do all that
you know drug dealing and it was thanks
to the CIA and now there's something
that they believe Obama had a scandal
that's kind of slowly coming out called
the Obama contra scandals basically that
the DEA was finding out that Hezbollah
was selling drugs in America and Obama
pulled the D off from investigating it
and that's like a lot
happens is like these foreign entities
get into the drug game here and make
money to fund their military exercises
through the drug money the u.s. it's a
way for them the fund proxy wars
basically where they can't officially be
involved in it so they fund these like
side armies to do a lot of their bidding
we see that happen a lot so basically we
have a lot of soldiers in many many
different countries that we're not
supposed to be in officially so they
have like fake passports and all that so
we have friends actually where their
parents are that exactly for many many
years in Latin America fighting wars
training guerrilla soldiers all that
stuff in the drug war or just like
guerilla warfare for politics or
whatever the reason but in most cases
it's to protect our business interests
or to get inside and set up our own
corporate or corporations or have
cooperative countries that we can
exploit so whether it's having our
companies going and doing the farming
there or controlling the resources there
but there's just so much [ __ ] that's
going on in the global scale that we
don't know like any of that stuff as
regular citizens but it happens and
that's how we stay number one
we like to destabilize people and then
be you know the real moneys in what we
call god guns oil and drugs yeah so we
make money selling the drugs and we make
money selling them the arms and then we
come in and we take out all their
natural resource happens all the [ __ ]
time man yeah there's a book called
tales of an economic hitman yeah I
believe but he basically his job was to
destabilize economies and throw wall
countries and keep them in heavy debt so
they could never be pay back was he like
in the CIA or something I think he
agency was government or he was private
but the government watched layers of
protection so they'll hire third party
and different groups to do certain
things kind of like how in the past they
use the military but now they they use
contractors yeah Blackwater DynCorp
right to do all the dirty work because
they're not responsible under
US law there are private companies so
there's all this [ __ ] that happens
outside globally where we're [ __ ] up
it's crazy yeah that went deep from the
drug [ __ ] but it's pretty dope dope no
pun intended yeah yeah so now they're
just trying to protect some guy to make
sure that she can still keep doing her
work and we should legalize drugs ma'am
we should decriminalize legalize drugs
there's no reason some goes to jail for
doing drugs it's the most ridiculous
thing
prostitution same way what's more
capitalist and prostitution supply and
demand and they they're just poor people
crimes yeah bill privatized jails up man
if I have a drug problem how does me
going to jail help that I have a drug
problem I quit doing drugs man but if
you throw me in jail I get a felony it's
so hard for me to rebound from that in
my life gonna get a job yeah how's
anyone gonna feel like you can be
trusted you can work you're a legitimate
person if you a see one strike they go I
don't wanna take my chances yep it makes
it infinitely harder so so I have this
whole theory that's why women get less
time for jail because they have a
certain amount of time that they can
have children so what's the best way you
throw a felony on her you put her in for
like the guys doing 50 she's doing five
she gets out in time now she's a felon
and she's having kids it's gonna be
really hard for her to support herself
and now you got kids born into the world
with two strikes against them and it's
just this vicious cycle to fill up all
the jails man and then they're trapped
in the welfare system yup and then the
boys get into privatized jail system oh
[ __ ] I see the connection that's [ __ ]
up
[Music]